ADRIAN LUDWIG: My
name is Adrian Ludwig.
I work at Google.
I'm the director for
Android security.
Let me be the 57th person
to welcome you to Next.
Thank you all for
coming to what is
my hometown of San Francisco.
I'm excited to
have you all here.
We have 59 minutes
and 24 seconds
to chat a little bit
about Android security.
So I'll probably spend
about 45 minutes or so
going through content,
and then hopefully we'll
have some time for
questions towards the end
to be able to go through.
And would welcome any questions
that you might have, and make
sure that we get
you the information
that you need to be making good
decisions about what you're
doing in your environment.
So I'm going to talk about
Android security, which
is a big topic.
We throw around numbers
in the world of Android
that sometimes boggle my mind.
You know, 1.4-plus billion
active users is an incredible
statistic.
And that number grows
every day by amounts
that you can't really fathom.
The number of people
in San Francisco
doesn't begin to approach
the number of new users
that we add to Android as an
ecosystem on a daily basis.
And so it's really
an honor to be
able to talk a little
bit about what we've
been doing at Google, but also
talk a little bit about how
we fit into the overall
ecosystem in terms
of protecting Android users.
Because we're just one
big but still very small
part of how it is that we're
approaching protections
in the Android ecosystem.
And so where do
we really fit in?
That's a good way to start
thinking about Android,
because it's very different
from other platforms.
Google is a shepherd or
steward for an ecosystem.
We're not the provider of the
platform in a strict sense.
We're not the maker
of all of the devices
that get used by users.
We're not the maker of
all of the applications
that get used by users.
And maybe this part's obvious,
we're not all of the users.
And so there's a lot
of different parties
that are involved in thinking
about how to have security
for an ecosystem of this scale.
We see our role as facilitating
application developers
by providing them
with a platform
that is safe by default,
that has APIs that allow them
to build very high
security applications,
or even if they're not
thinking about security, to be
able to benefit from the
security of the platform.
We see users as basically not
wanting to think about security
but having an expectation that
security will be provided.
And so we've
designed the devices
to be secure by
default. And then
we've built layer upon layer
of protections in addition
to that that are really
transparent so that users
don't really need to
worry about security.
And then on the
device maker side,
we work very closely
with partners--
large companies,
small companies,
individual developers,
to make sure
that the devices that get
out into the ecosystem
have security protections.
And there's a variety
of tools that we have.
And we will release
to open source.
But then we do things like build
the compatibility test suite,
and a compatibility
definition document
that can define the security
model across the Android
ecosystem so that we
know there's consistency
across the ecosystem.
And then one of the
things that we've
been investing a
lot in that I'll
spend a few minutes towards
the end talking about
is making sure that devices
are receiving security updates.
And optimizing security updates
in an open source environment
turns out to be a pretty
interesting and complicated
problem.
The security industry and
sort of the software industry
spent 10 or 15
years figuring out
how to deliver security updates
for closed source platforms.
And Android has been, I
think, at the forefront
of figuring out how to do
that for open source as well.
And so we'll talk
a bit about that.
The way I tend to think
about the problem,
because it's so big, and
because it's so diverse,
is to focus on three
different areas.
The first is on the
platform itself, the code
that people think of as Android.
And so we'll spend some
time thinking about that.
Then we'll get into
services, things
that are delivered as
applications, most of them
by Google, but also
by third parties that
add additional
security protections.
And then the last
is what we've done
to work with other parties
in the ecosystem to make sure
that friction that can
sometimes impede security
doesn't get in the way of
security being delivered,
and in particular,
around updates
and how we're enabling that.
So my background, for
people who are curious,
is in creation and
delivery of exploits,
going back quite a ways.
And so I was sort of on the
more offensive side of security.
And one of the things that
was really interesting
from the offensive
side of security
is if you look at
security primitives,
basically 35-ish years
ago the US government
put together something
called the Orange Book.
And there are similar types of
things that were put together
by other governments--
that have been put together
in other places as well.
But there is a fairly
well-defined set
of expected security
primitives that
would exist on a secure device.
And what's interesting is
it's taken a really long time
for the software industry
to evolve to a point
where it's actually providing
all those primitives.
When I think about Android
and its sort of phase
in that evolution,
I put it right
next to what I think of as the
other mobile operating system.
So Android, iOS, Chrome
OS, all uniformly
provide the same
primitives, which
are the ones that were described
almost 35 years ago in Orange
Book and these other
manuals, but that
just took a really long time
for them to get broadly adopted.
And those are isolation
of applications,
making sure that there
was cryptographically
strong device integrity
that was rooted
in a hardware route of trust.
Then there was
something interesting
that happened in
those intervening
30 years, which was the
realization that there
were bugs in software.
And so one of the areas
that we've invested very,
very heavily in is what we
refer to as exploit mitigation
and attack surface minimisation,
which is technology
is designed to make
sure that, even if we've
made a mistake--
because let me tell you,
we make a lot of mistakes.
Google is very good
at making mistakes.
That's why we have
launch and iterate
as one of our philosophies.
That's why updates are
so important for all
these platforms-- but even
if there is a mistake,
hopefully exploit
mitigation can make
exploitation of that in the
real world more challenging.
Over the last
couple of days we've
been looking very closely at
a number of vulnerabilities
that we didn't know about
before that became public.
And we've been sort of analyzing
those and thinking through--
how did exploit
mitigations prevent these
from actually being able to
be used in the real world?
And what are the
technologies that we
need to be continuing to invest
in so that even if there's
an issue that we
don't know about,
we can prevent it from
being a successful exploit?
And that's an area that
we've invested in a lot.
Management basically
comes down to enterprises
and applications.
We want to know what the
state of a device is.
And so we've been
investing a lot
in making sure that those
APIs are available as well.
When I look at Android--
and the other mobile operating
systems for that matter--
I see, basically,
complete implementation
of all of the best practices
at a platform level.
So we're actually in
a really good place
across the mobile
operating systems.
That's very well and
very substantially
differentiated from either
server infrastructure
or from other
desktop environments.
So we're in a pretty good place.
One of the interesting
points, though,
about the mobile
operating systems
is the velocity with which new
technology can be delivered.
So I want to talk about one of
those new pieces of technology.
Encryption is a feature
that has existed on Android
for, I think, about six years.
It was on devices,
but it was not
enabled by default. Users
were able to turn it on.
Enterprises demanded
that it be present.
It was in the
checklist of things
that had to be on
a device in order
to deploy it into an enterprise.
But the reality was
nobody turned it on.
That began to change roughly two
years ago with the Android 6.0
release where the default
configuration on Android
devices was to enable it for
devices that were capable of--
from a performance
standpoint-- of having
it functioning and not
disruptive to the user
experience.
And so in the span
of about two years
we went from basically
nobody having encryption
enabled on Android devices,
even though it was available,
to having over 80% of
new Android devices
that are coming
out be encrypted.
And so that adoption
rate I think
is one of the unique
characteristics from a security
standpoint of mobile--
is if we find some other
technology like encryption that
is really important
to defend users,
you can expect that it will
be adopted very, very quickly.
And this is turnover rate,
not in a sort of slow--
or not in a highly
managed environment.
This is for the
overall ecosystem.
This is for hundreds
of millions of devices
and how quickly those security
features can be rolled out.
So having this sort of velocity
of security innovation,
I think, is one of
the things that's
really attractive about the
mobile platforms at this point.
It's also one of the
reasons why investing
in innovative security research
is really important because--
this sounds trite, but we're
running out of areas to invest.
We have encryption.
We have verified boot.
We have good isolation.
We have good sandboxing.
We're basically
getting to a point
where we have hardware
route of trust,
where what is really important
is the flaws and the bugs.
And so this is an
area that Google--
and in particular Chrome--
we're very, very
innovative about four
or five years ago
in saying, we're
going to deploy bug bounties.
And Android at this point
is one of the largest bounty
programs in the world.
One of the unique
characteristics of the Android
bounty program is the
amount of investment
we're seeing in
terms of researchers
in areas of the world that
historically have not been
prominent in security research.
I'm hinting at
China, specifically,
where we're seeing a significant
number of the researchers that
are looking at Android and
finding vulnerabilities
on Android are based in China.
So we've tapped into security
research and security
innovation that really
is not visible to any
of the other platform providers,
which is pretty interesting.
I have no doubt
that worldwide there
are people looking for the bugs,
but only on Android are they
actually then reporting
them into the vendor
and allowing us to make
the platform more secure.
So those are some of
the things that we're
doing at the platform level.
I want to spend a
few minutes talking
as well about the
changes and sort of work
that we've done on services.
And to provide a
little bit of context,
services historically
have been something
that is left to a third party.
If you look at the
desktop platforms,
for example, Microsoft, Apple,
and the other desktop platform
providers said, let's create
an ecosystem of third party
vendors--
Symantec, McAfee, Kaspersky,
et cetera, et cetera, right?
Dozens, if not hundreds,
of those security research
and anti-virus and
security providers.
And that was a model that
worked relatively well.
But it had significant gaps
in terms of the coverage
that those solutions
were able to provide,
and in terms of the
ability for those solutions
to influence the
direction of the platform
and also respond to knowledge
that the platform provider had.
So about five to
six years ago when
we were looking at Android,
we said, you know what?
Rather than having that
capability be entirely
external to the platform
provided by third parties,
let's make sure that we provide
a best of breed set of security
services integrated
with the applications
that we're putting
onto these devices.
And so Google Play and
Google Play Services
incorporated a suite
of security services
and made it available for all
devices that have the Google
applications on them.
That's a very different
model than what
we've seen on other platforms
in the mobile space, where
instead, those other platforms
have said security services are
basically forboden, or are
very significantly impeded.
They're not provided by
the platform provider.
And in fact, it's very
difficult to implement
on those other platforms.
And so Android has taken a
very different direction there.
And it's one that, I
think, over time is going
to be really, really important.
So when I talk about
security services,
and I've given you
sort of that framing,
here are the types of
services that we're
providing right now, out
of the box, on any device
that has Google Play on it.
The first one is what
we call Verify Apps.
Security is not an
area where we've had
a ton of marketing investments.
So these are not
super sexy names.
We need to add some
X's and Y's and things
to make these more exciting.
Verify Apps does exactly
what you would expect.
It verifies the
apps that are being
installed onto the device.
In addition to checking
the certificate that's
used to sign the
application, Verify Apps
checks with Google at
the time of installation
to see whether this is an
application that exposes
the user to a heightened risk.
Is it-- I'll use the sort of
desktop nomenclature-- is it
a virus?
Turns out on Android
we don't have
viruses for various reasons,
inclusive of the fact
that apps are signed.
And so the viral
mutation that is
the heart of why we call
things viruses doesn't apply.
But is it a piece of malware?
Or is it something that could
be a potentially harmful
application?
And so every Android device
that has the Google applications
on it does these
real-time checks
at the time of installation.
And then, again, in the
background on an ongoing basis
we check all of the
applications on the device
to see whether or not it
could be a potentially
harmful application.
That has incredible
consequences,
which we'll talk about
it in just a second,
in terms of how clean we've
been able to keep the ecosystem.
Another thing that we
have on Android devices
is what we call
the sensor network.
Sensor network is exactly
what you'd expect.
It's a network of
sensors on these devices
that checks for non
application-based security
risks.
So beyond verifying the
apps, we also are looking at
is this device
connecting to a network
that's potentially hostile?
Are we seeing attempted
exploitation of media file
formats on these devices?
And I'll talk a little bit about
what the consequences of that
is.
So we've got that across
a large number of devices.
Developer APIs, I
think, are probably
one of the things that are
even more interesting for you
folks, which is taking the
information from Verify
Apps and the sensor network and
exposing that so that you can
incorporate the intelligence
that Google is generating
about what's going
on in the ecosystem
into your own security
model, and into how
you're thinking about those
devices and those applications.
So you can basically
say, I don't
want to have my app at
work if there's ever
been a piece of
malware on this device.
And Google's going to
provide the services for you
to be able to do that.
And the last service that we
have there is finding your lost
device, right?
Or being able to respond in
the event that a device is lost
or stolen.
The net of these services
is incredible visibility
into the ecosystem.
And to give you a
flavor for it, we've
got over a billion and a half
devices that are protected
right now with these services.
They're checking in on
a very regular basis.
So on average it's about
once every other day,
where we're doing about 750
million scans of the ecosystem,
individual devices around the
ecosystem on a daily basis.
And the number of applications
that we're looking at
is also incredibly large.
Because that's one of
the largest concerns that
exist in the ecosystem is
what are the applications that
are there.
The result of that is
that we're able to manage
the level of risk in the
ecosystem quite effectively.
This is a graph
going back to 2014--
so almost three
years at this point--
showing the rate of
devices having what
we classify as a potentially
harmful application
installed on a device.
This is a malware rate,
to put it quite bluntly,
for the world.
And I want to call that out--
most malware rates that exist
are from highly
managed environments.
If you're in an
enterprise, you might
be looking at-- what's
the frequency with which
a piece of malware
gets onto my Mac fleet,
or gets onto my iPhone fleet,
or gets onto my Windows fleet?
For the desktop platforms,
those numbers often
are on the order of 10% or so.
A managed environment
with users who are--
have active anti-virus
running on their device,
on their desktop platform, they
might even have white listing.
There may be other
characteristics or security
defenses that are in
place on those devices.
But they still
have a malware rate
that's roughly an
order of magnitude
higher than what we've seen
on unmanaged Android devices
worldwide.
So a very different statistic.
And we see sort of roughly an
order of magnitude cleaner.
In fact, if you
look at something
that's a little bit more
similar to what your enterprise
fleet might look like, it would
be the second number, which
is for Android devices that are
only installing applications
from Google Play, what do we
see as their malware rate?
And here it's actually
about 120th of the rate
that you see for the average
across the ecosystem.
It's 0.05.
So a full order of
magnitude cleaner.
And that's like the basic,
most simple management
that you can do is
to just say only
allow installation of
apps from Google Play.
If you take
additional steps that
are provided through EMMs,
like white listing or filtering
the applications, you could
imagine that you could cut this
down even more substantially.
So we're in an
incredibly clean place
for the overall ecosystem, which
is great if you're doing Beta C
or delivering applications
directly to consumers.
And if you're talking about
managing within your own fleet,
you're able to get much, much
cleaner than that as well.
These scans also
give us visibility
into exploitation of issues
that are found out in the wild.
We have a sensor network
that's been delivered out
to over 1.4 billion devices.
And we're able to look
back both in real time
but also historically to
understand the level of risk
that devices might
be exposed to.
This is a chart.
These are the three
vulnerabilities
that have received probably
the most attention on Android
over the last four years.
They were sort of the
marquee Android vulnerability
at the 2013, '14, and
'15 blackout conferences
held in Las Vegas in sort
of the middle of the summer.
So master key, fake ID, and
Stagefright sort of in order.
Two of these are vulnerabilities
that specifically
affected the verification
of signatures
at the time of installation.
And so we have
perfect visibility
for devices that have Verify
Apps and Safetynet turned on
into the level of exploitation,
because we actually
checked every single install
that happens on those devices
through Verify Apps.
So we can go back and
we can with confidence
say there was zero exploitation
before those issues became
public.
And that even after
they became public,
the level of exploitation
that took place
was extraordinarily low.
And then you can contrast that
to the level of communication
that existed in the media.
Often what I like to do is
look at our data and say,
did more people
read about how scary
this thing was relative
to the number of people
who were affected?
And almost uniformly that's
going to be the case.
There are a lot more people that
are frightened by these things
than are actually
affected by them,
which puts us in a
pretty good place.
Stagefright was a watershed,
I think, for the Android
ecosystem at large.
In terms of the
effect that it had,
it ended up driving
much more rapid adoption
of security bulletins
and security patches
in the ecosystem.
We'll talk more about
that in just a second.
But what's interesting
about it is here
we are going on
a year and a half
after that issue became public.
And there still are no confirmed
instances of any exploitation.
One of the things that
was really fascinating
over the last couple of
days is taking a look
at a new trove of
security vulnerabilities
and realizing that
none of them affected
media server, none of them
referred to Stagefright.
So despite the
level of attention
that was focused on
that particular issue,
it doesn't seem to have had
an actual effect in terms
of the user security
that's out there.
Again, not claiming
that it didn't.
I'm claiming that we haven't
seen it, which is, I think,
pretty interesting that
the distance between what's
happening in the
ecosystem and the level
of communication around risk
that exists in the ecosystem.
So if you're interested
in the services
and getting a deeper dive
into how those services work,
Edward Cunningham,
who is the product
manager for those services,
is going to talk tomorrow.
He's going to go into
how we're using machine
learning to detect specific
types of attacks that might be
taking place against
users, some of the work
that we've been doing
with neural networks
and detecting those, and talk
through a number of areas
of investment that we're making.
So I think that is actually one
of the most interesting things
that's going on is those
advancements and services.
The other area that I
want to talk a bit about
is ecosystem updates.
And there's two different
areas that we're investing in.
Google, obviously,
has an obligation
to build the most secure
version of the platform
that we possibly can and to
get that out to as many people
as we possibly can.
But there are two
other parties that
have an impact on the
security of a device.
The first is
application developers,
and let me talk a little
bit about my experience
as someone who came from
the world of application
developers.
Prior to being at
Google, I was working
on security for desktop
applications, head of security
at Adobe.
And what was interesting to
me in the Windows ecosystem
is for the first
handful of years
all of the focus on security was
at the operating system level.
And then circa 2004, 2005
there was a transition where
exploitation shifted
from the platform itself
into the key applications.
And what were those
key applications?
Adobe PDF and Reader, Adobe
Flash were two of them.
The browsers were another one--
Firefox, IE.
And Chrome wasn't
there at the time but
quickly became one of the
areas that was the focal point,
and it is still today.
We also began to see a lot of
exploitation that was targeted
at other document formats.
And so what was
interesting was no matter
how hard we had made the
platform looking at Windows,
there was this shift in
where the weak spot was.
And so on the Android
side, we wanted
to make sure that that
shift doesn't take place.
And so we're very
proactively beginning
to look at
application developers
and make sure that they're
in a much better place.
By default, since
most applications
on Android are written in Java--
which is a typesafe language
and a memory safe language--
by default, they're
already in a better place.
But we wanted to see if we
could do more than that.
So the approach that
we took was beginning
to use the scanning services
that we had built to find
malware and repurposing that.
And so the repurposing
that we did
was to look for
basic vulnerabilities
in applications.
This is a picture of the
set of new technologies
that we introduced where we
were looking for vulnerabilities
over the last year.
They range from things like
libupnp and Apache Cordova
where what we were
looking for was
an old version of a library
that had a known vulnerability.
We scan all the applications
that are in Google Play,
and then we notify
those developers, hey,
you're running an
old version of this.
In many instances, the
developer's like, hey, thanks.
I didn't even know that.
And they immediately fix it.
In some instances, the
developer's like, clueless,
hasn't been doing anything,
isn't paying any attention,
and the app continues to exist.
The next time that they go
to update their application,
add a new feature, ship a
new release, get new users,
they're told you can't do that
until that application has
had the vulnerability
that we identified fixed.
And so this has ended up
having a very significant sort
of-- what I think of as raising
the base level of security that
exists in the applications.
So the simplest one is
something like checking
for a vulnerable
version of a library.
There are more
sophisticated ones as well,
like the SSL Error Handler,
where what we were looking for
is whether an application
is handling SSL
errors in a way that's safe.
If you check to
see-- you've enabled
SSL on a particular
network connection,
you get back an SSL error.
If what you say is,
that's OK, just connect,
that's probably not
what was intended,
or you wouldn't have
turned on SSL at all.
But it's also a
very common thing
that a developer will
do in a testing phase
for an application, right?
They'll say, I don't really
have a current certificate
on my test server, and so I'm
going to allow the connection
to go through.
And so what we've
done here is we've
looked for those
types of instances
where the default
handler is one that's
allowing all connections.
We flag the application.
We tell the developer,
look, this is the problem.
And then they have the option
of either disabling SSL,
if that's what was
their intention,
or fixing it so that the SSL
Error Handler is actually
a sane SSL Error Handler.
So there's a variety
of different levels
of sophistication on
the types of warnings
that we're able to
give to developers.
I mentioned that
in some instances
we're using sort of more
strong enforcement mechanisms
through Google Play to try to
make sure that these devices
or that these applications
are being brought up to date.
And so that's had a
pretty significant impact.
This is a graph of the
number of applications
that have been fixed as a
result of us delivering warnings
to them.
So in 2016, almost 300,000
unique applications
that had their
security improved.
So incredible scale
in terms of being
able to deliver security
protections at the application
level.
So application developers
are one area of focus for us.
Another is around devices and
the devices that are being
built using Android software.
As you may know--
I expect many people do, but
there probably are a few that
don't--
Google doesn't ship
software on devices,
with the exception of the
Pixel and the Nexus devices.
So roughly 1% of the
Android ecosystem
is binaries that was--
it consisted of devices
that have binaries
that were built by Google.
The other 99%, an OEM takes
source code from an open source
project, compiles that,
and then delivers that
as the software on
top of those devices.
They go through certification,
and CDD, and a variety
of other compatibility
requirements
in order to be able to make
sure that the devices work well
with the rest of the
Android ecosystem.
But ultimately it's
the device maker
that is responsible for
delivering the software
onto those devices.
And so one of the
great challenges
is how do we make sure that
the devices that are out there
have the most recent
version of the software,
and that any changes that
might have been made by the OEM
don't negatively affect
security on those devices?
And so we work really closely
with device makers to make sure
that they're doing that.
One of the other things that
we work with are carriers.
So this is a picture to
give you a rough sense
for how many carriers there are
worldwide that we're working
with on an active basis.
So there are probably
a few more than this.
This is a snapshot
taken not too long ago.
But there are 351
different carriers that
are out there in the world.
Carriers-- in the
United States we're
talking about AT&T, Verizon,
T-Mobile, Sprint, and a number
of other ones as well.
Carriers play a very
significant role
because often they
are the source
of purchase for a device.
You go into a carrier
store, you buy a device.
They also have requirements
about the functionality
that exists on those devices.
They're very strongly involved
in the delivery of software
on those devices.
They require applications
that might be installed.
They require configuration
to work on their network.
In some instances, the network
protocols are different.
CDMA versus GSM-- although
that's tending to break down
at this point--
it was one of the
variations that would
exist within the US networks.
And so we're working
with these carriers
to define what software is
going to be on these devices
and what the
requirements are for it.
Now, historically,
cell phones did not
get updated basically at all.
And there was a very
strong resistance
to updating software on those
devices because of stability
at the network level.
And so the carriers,
for many years,
had been defining
a testing regime
around software for these
devices that was designed--
correctly, I would argue--
to minimize the rate at
which device updates could
be delivered to those devices.
They didn't want devices to be
changing because change created
instability both
at a network level,
but also at an
individual user level.
If the software
changed, that was bad.
There are other factors
as well around congestion
and consumption of bandwidth.
And so in the
Android environment
we're dealing with a software
stack that's much more complex.
We're dealing with
vulnerabilities
that are being found.
We talked about
Stagefright and Master Key
and a few of the
other ones earlier.
And so there was a bit
of a cognitive dissonance
between the approach
the carriers
had adopted of minimizing the
rate at which the updates could
be delivered, maximizing the
amount of testing that could be
done, and the need
to deliver security
updates in a timely fashion.
So over the last year or so--
but going back
further than that.
But for sure over
the last year or so,
we've been working a
lot with the carriers
to differentiate between
updates to devices
that were nonsecurity
specific versus ones
that were security specific.
And so beginning of 2016
roughly, the average update
to an Android
device, at a minimum,
from the point
where an OEM said,
I'm done with this update,
I'm ready to ship it out
to customers--
until it had gone through
carrier testing and approval
was on the order of
six to nine weeks.
What was also interesting
about that is usually
that had to be scheduled
another six to nine weeks ahead
of time.
So we're really talking
about an 18-week period
basically from when
the OEM is done
to when an update could make it
into the hands of a consumer.
So very difficult to
deliver security updates
in a timely fashion.
Over the last year
and a half, we've
worked with the
carriers-- basically
with all the major
carriers, about 40 or 50
of them worldwide-- to make
sure that if an update was
a security only update,
then that could be delivered
in less than a week.
So they've gone
through and said, OK,
if issues are in
security bulletins,
and if we're provided with
the software from Google,
then we're going to be willing
to let those go through
at a much faster
approval process.
And so we've taken
advantage of that
to make sure that we're able to
deliver security updates very
quickly to devices.
So we've sort of eliminated some
of the cost associated with it,
but we haven't
eliminated a lot of it.
So the next thing that
we've been investing in
over the last year or so is
in working with specific OEMs
to try to refine what their
development process looks like.
And so I want to
give you a little bit
of a flavor for where we've
been focusing on our effort.
So beginning of last
year, 2016, we sat down
and we said, OK, we're trying
to change an ecosystem that
has over 60,000 unique devices
in it to get it to a point
where it's able to
deliver security
updates in a timely fashion.
How are we going
to approach that?
So we chopped off the top
OEMs in the flagship devices
for those top OEMs.
And we said, we're
going to focus initially
on updating just those devices,
the ones that you might
be familiar with because you've
seen them like, on a billboard,
or they cost $600.
And they're receiving a lot.
Those are the ones
that we think is
the best opportunity to
work with OEMs to refactor
their approach.
So we talked to
the top five OEMs.
We said, let's look at just
your flagship devices because,
remember, a lot of these
OEMs produce literally
dozens if not hundreds.
So it ended up being about 29
device models across those five
OEMs.
The flagship in
North America might
be different from the
flagship in Europe,
might be different from
the flagship in Asia.
So there's a little
bit of complexity there
that may not be
obvious as a consumer.
I like to anchor this
and say, at this point
you're already talking
about more device
models than any other platform.
You've already-- like, we're not
talking about the full range.
We're not even talking about a
tiny fraction of the ecosystem.
But just looking at these
you're already talking
about more complexity
than any other ecosystem
that exists in the world.
Now, I mentioned
carriers, and the fact
that carriers like to have
customization for devices.
And so those 29 different device
models when you sort of blow
them up across all
the different carriers
and the customisations,
what you end up with is--
just looking at the flagship
models for the top five OEMs--
5,000 unique builds
of Android that
are currently being serviced
that are flagship devices.
OK.
That's 5,000 different
development teams out there
in the world.
Think about that-- it's
5,000 Git repositories.
It's 5,000 QA teams.
It's, I don't know, probably
10,000 different VPEs
of engineering, all of
whom need to be working
in synchronicity in order to
be able to deliver updates
on these devices.
And so what started
as a really simple,
hey, let's just update
devices on a monthly basis,
turned out to be a little bit
more complicated than that.
And so we've been working very
steadily with those top five
OEMs and others in the
ecosystem as well--
but for the purposes of this
we'll focus on those top five--
to make sure that
these 5,000 devices
are being brought up to date.
The sort of output, because
who cares about the process?
What you really care
about is the output.
The output is, the beginning
of 2016, about somewhere
on the order of, I
say, less than 20%.
I think it's on the
order of 12% to 13%
of devices were up to
date in the last 60 days.
So basically, the last security
bulletin that was available
was on those devices.
That's just for flagships.
The number was even lower
for the broader ecosystem.
By the end of 2016, we
had brought that number up
to over 50%.
So on the flagship devices there
was a very significant change.
Over 50% of devices
that are up to date.
That's not-- we're not done.
I just want to make sure
I'm expressing that.
Like, this is great progress.
20 to 50-- huge, right?
The line is going
up to the right.
But, you know, there's
another 45-ish percent
that we need to figure out how
to get those patched as well.
And then again, this is
just for flagship devices.
If you're looking
in your environment,
you can hone in a little bit
on specific characteristics
that may make your
environment safer.
The flagship devices
that were brought
in through top carriers in
North America or in Europe
have an even higher
patch rate, over 70%.
This does mean, by the way, that
if you bought your device not
from one of those carriers,
then you're necessarily
going to have a percentage
that must be below 50%
because they average out, right?
So you want to
think a little bit
about where you're sourcing
devices from and using them
in your environment.
You also have the ability to
be more selective about which
devices you want to purchase
if you're in an environment
where you're thinking
about how to source them.
One device that we recommend
from Google is the Pixel.
We consistently have an
update rate of over 90%.
Patches are made
immediately available.
I can get you details about
other manufacturers that
also provide that as well.
They're a little
bit more sensitive
about us talking about the
devices that they're making
and their update rates.
But we can get you more
information about that.
If you have questions, just
feel free to reach out to me
and I can help get you in
contact with somebody that
can get you that information.
There's a really
simple way if you
want to have an
update rate that's
a really simple, good one.
We provide an API, which is
build version security patch
level.
If you're an EMM, you can
write a policy that says,
I only want to be running on
devices that are up to date.
You can say 90 days, 60 days.
I would recommend 90
days simply because there
are a number of devices that--
basically because your update
cycle is on a 30-day cycle,
roughly.
And so if devices are more than
a couple of weeks out of date,
they'll very quickly--
A, they'll almost every month
end up around 30 days, and then
B, it's not uncommon that
they'll end up going past 60.
And so giving your
users the opportunity
to actually apply the
patch, get it up to date,
is the approach that
we would recommend.
So we generally say 90 days is
probably the right approach.
And so that gives you a
sense for the progress
that we've made.
Before we close
on that, I do want
to say, I think over
the next two years
or so we'll continue to see
an increase in broad based
adoption of security updates
around the Android ecosystem.
That's my sort of
forecast is that it's
going take about two to three
years before we get to a point
where you have 80% of all the
devices that are up to date.
That it's taking
time for the OEMs
to ingest and modify
their processes
to be able to deliver updates
on a more regular basis.
But all the trajectory is
in the right direction.
The last thing that
I want to mention
is if data is your thing and you
want to know a little bit more
about Android
security and the work
that we've been doing there,
every year for the last three
years we've produced an annual
security year in review.
It's about an 80-page
document this year.
It'll be coming out in
the next couple of weeks.
And I would encourage
you to take a look at it.
It breaks down all
the malware data.
It breaks down update
rates, breaks down
a lot of the features
and investments
that we've been
making in that space
so you can really
understand what's going on
across the ecosystem at large.
And the last thing that
I want to sort of note
is I think often in the
security space we focus
so much on the technology that's
sort of at the platform level
or at the operating system level
that we lose sight of the fact
that, especially in
the mobile space,
we've really already begun to
unlock business models that
were not possible previously.
And we've done that from a
security standpoint, as well.
This one cracks me
up a little bit.
This is a picture of people
playing Pokemon Go in Japan.
There are similar pictures
from around San Francisco.
I just couldn't find one
that had quite as many heads
packed into a little space
all staring at their screens.
And gaming in particular
on mobile devices
has been an incredible
driver of security.
I think the security
community often
will sort of poo-poo it
as, ah, it's just DRM,
or, ah, it's just games.
But this is a billion
dollar business
that depends upon the
hardest threat model, which
is that the person who has
the device in their hand
is trying to break it.
And so the fact that they're
able to build this business
depends on two things-- one,
it depends on the core security
properties of the
platform, and then two,
it depends upon the fact
that they as developers
realized that they
needed to use some
of the more sophisticated
features that were available
and services.
So they were one of the early
adopters of something called
SafetyNet.Attestation
where Google tries
to assess whether this is
a device that's currently
operating in a
good state or not,
pass that information up to
the application developer.
So I think what's
interesting is they've
managed to do that and build
that billion dollar business.
I don't have any expectation.
Maybe some of you are building
your entire business on mobile.
Maybe you're not.
But if you are, there
are other people
that are doing that as well.
And they're scaling to
billions of dollars,
even in a very high
risk environment.
And that's something that
I want to flag, right?
Because I think, often,
especially in security
there's this reversion
to change aversion that
makes it impossible for
people to say, oh, my gosh,
I couldn't do this on
Windows because there
was so much piracy, and there
was so much flexibility.
But on mobile, it's actually not
just possible, it's happening.
And games are one of the
primary drivers of it.
Similarly, payment
infrastructure
is something that we've
seen very rapid adoption
of based on the security
properties of the platform.
The fact that we're able to go
into major payment operators
and say, trust the platform,
here is the capabilities of it,
is really incredible.
And it's something that these
folks depend upon trust zone,
they depend upon hardware
security in a way
that others haven't
been able to.
And I think that's
one of the reasons why
when you look at the most
targeted highest risk
users in the world,
more and more we're
seeing an acknowledgement
that mobile devices are
necessary for them
to communicate,
and investments
that are being made
are sufficient for them to be
able to use these platforms.
So it's a really
exciting time for me
to know that people who
are the most at risk,
whether that be world
leaders, or whether that
be dissidents who
are being targeted,
they can rely on
the technology they
have in a way that never was
possible before from a security
standpoint.
So that's pretty
exciting for me.
So this was sort of
the think about how
it is relevant in your
environment as well
and how to take advantage of it.